if you thought Rick and Daryl had issues
with the walking dead take a look at it
for most of us when our loved ones die
they are laid to rest for eternity not
so for one community in Indonesia in a
ceremony called the cleaning of the
corpses families raise their deceased
relatives from their graves dress them
in new clothes fix their hair and repair
their coffins then they walk the dead
around the province so they can observe
with the living okay so as Westerners
that actually seems kind of hard to
believe but after I read the story and I
was thinking about a little bit more we
have pretty bonkers practices related to
death - right like my grandma one of
them got cremated I mean they literally
just burned her body to ash
the other one was buried traditionally
but like I saw her in a coffin and
dressed up like we do these weird things
so really is this practice any weirder I
know viscerally there's something about
it yeah pretty weird every year to dig
them up and dress them up and walk them
around and like that's a little bit
different than observing in a coffin er
yeah some like final respect that you
pay to someone this is like an ongoing
like dig them up and carry them around
and this just right the walking around
would seem to me to be the like I could
I guess like I'm really I'm trying to be
open-minded about this like they have
their traditions that's that's great so
dressing them up that's one thing but
they really they're like parading them
around like it there seems to be like
there would be health issues or
something right yeah I would think that
well also I just don't understand how
it's physically possible in some senses
like the malleability factor I feel
would start going down at a pretty rapid
pace you know like how our limbs
cracking after they just attach them
back on right it must be much more fun
to play with like a newer dad and how
long do you continue doing it like do
you just eventually just kind of carry
like a bushel of their bones around town
right with like a hat on top that's
really creepy right I mean I don't know
at what point they stopped but I just
don't understand also how they actually
get the clothes on with
than crumbling to pieces when I first
pulled up the article I have to admit I
actually felt that woman I was a whoa
she wasn't good for her so good for
making one last hoorah around town yeah
what do you guys think about like the
general fascination with zombies I feel
like zombies are in like a little
Renaissance right now Walking Dead
there's like five other shows I always
loved zombies from when I was a kid and
they want to eat our brains you like
your brain what's going on I I mean I
think it's interesting it's you know
like a fantasy type of thing if vampires
and zombies and you know people like to
believe in or you know be entertained by
these things but like it's not literal
this is the right you think it's more
about like the zombies themselves or
it's just like the fascination is more
about just like this apocalyptic yeah
we're obsessed with it and I think thing
but I also think like it's supernatural
or whatever you want to call it
creatures kind of make waves in terms of
popularity like vampires had their huge
day yeah werewolves had their little
blip of a thing then and succeeded as
much as Ami's are now really taking over
right so we had like true God gave us
we're on that everything
Twilight then a little bit a little
you're a little werewolf and now we're
on the zombies what's next aliens
started off with like x-files I think
aliens need to make a comeback right or
it could be just be like clones of Will
Smith's kids oh that would be a hard if
if they brought you guys back after you
were dead how would you want to be
dressed would you be dressed like
yourself now or do you want to just
really go over the top I think I'll be
cremated to make sure that can never
happen I do want to be cremated yeah
yeah you want to be well they have these
actually really cool things where you
can be cremated and then put into like a
pot yes and then like a tree will grow
did we yes did I do
you know I just I've seen that
everywhere that's cool yeah I'll be a
tree so there literally is something
there doing it I think it started in
Portland I can't remember what it's
called uh Pam but they literally will
take your remains put it into a garden
and then like your family you can eat
like mint I feel like a non edible tree
yeah
alright last thought on this is there
something about the story that's
actually kind of beautiful like I know
it's also it seems kind of silly we can
joke about it but like just how
different humans are all over the place
and that we all have our different
traditions or whatever works out there's
something kind of beautiful about this
well I mean I think that there I think
there is you know there celebrating life
whereas I feel like in in this culture
we kind of we tend to you know mourn it
which is natural you know mourning loss
but I think you know we put a lot of
sadness behind it and they're putting
celebration and we do weird [ __ ] with it
we filled them up with formaldehyde we
make them look like living dolls I mean
it's very weird at least this they're
you know taking them in their naturally
decrepit remains and radium do you feel
that but there's something like just
interesting about how we are there tons
of us on this planet we all kind of be a
little bit differently yeah that's
that's whatever makes them happy
whatever makes you dead people happy
anyway what do you think is this creepy
is it cool let us know in the comments
right down below anyway thanks guys for
doing this and we will be back